>>Dick: OK thanks for coming everybody to
the -- it's a long title; Technology, Innovation,
Computer Science, and More: A VC Panel.
I'm Dick Costello.
I'm the COO at Twitter, but I’m not why
you're here; these guys are why you're here.
With me are, I'm gonna do the introductions
so that we don't do the whole 10 minute introduction
apiece and then we've only got a few minutes
left.
So I'm gonna do the introductions for them
and then dive right into questions and then
leave you guys a bunch of time for questions.
So we've got Albert Wenger from Union Square
Ventures.
Chris Dixon, the tall guy with the glasses
from Hunch.
Dave McClure from, do we still say we're from
500 hats? Dave? Yes.
All right.
Brad Feld from Foundry Group.
And Paul Graham from Y Combinator.
Okay?
Thanks guys.
So these guys are all tech.
I would say you're technologically based VC's.
You've all coded at some point in your life,
fair enough?
Good.
So the first question then is, right off the
bat, I wanna ask you guys is, would you invest
in a start up with non-technical founders?
And why and how is technology so important
to your investments?
Most importantly would you invest in a start
up with non, non-technological founders?
It's not that hard a question.
>>Paul: Yes.
>>Dick: [Laughs]
>>Paul: You mean only non technical founders?
>>Dick: Yeah
>>Paul: Ah, yes we would, and we have.
In fact the guy we invested in is back there
-- Haj Tagar, he now works for Y Combinator.
But what we care most about is how sort of
determined and formidable the founders are,
right.
There’s some people who are just gonna cut
a swath through the world getting what they
want.
And we want to invest in them.
So we would invest in a start up founded by
non-hackers if they were that sort of people.
However, if they had any brains, they would
realize that they needed some hackers to make
a product, right?
And so if they're the kind of people who get
what they need in life then they probably
ought to have a line on some hackers by the
time we see them, right?
Because you're gonna need hackers.
‘Cause if you're smart and determined, you’re
probably already gonna have them, you're gonna
have talked somebody into being your hacker,
so.
We would invest in people who weren’t technical
but it’s a bad sign if they don't have some
hackers pretty near by, right?
>>David: I guess I would make the distinction,
like first there's, there’s kind of like
truly non technical people, or like non-internet
people who are like English Majors and then
they worked at Proctor & Gamble in marketing
or whatever, and these are people who like
don't even do the Internet and that kind of
stuff and that's like one type of non-technical.
And then there are people who I think are
kind of are active web users and kind of Internet
people, and sometimes great user experience
user people aren't necessarily you know, hard
core technical people, I would sort of consider
those like internet people though.
And I think those, and then I think the third
category is kind of hard core engineers.
I would sort of say it also depends so much
on the start up, the type of stuff that I
think most people here invest in.
The best teams probably have a really strong
technical person and a really strong product
person.
The product person might not actually be like,
like whatever like, writing Python or whatever,
but they kind of get the whole thing, and
this and that.
I think they're in some, like I, there's one
company I invested in called Gerson Lehrman
Group which was a, sort of a, what I would
call a business model innovation out of Wall
Street.
And these guys knew Wall Street and this and
that, and they didn't really need to have
-- it wasn't really a technology innovation
as much as a business model.
So I think it just depends.
>>Dick: So let me kind of push on this a little
bit with Brad and Albert.
A couple of MBA's come into your office, they’re
non technical MBA's and they've got a business
plan around a digital media start up.
How do you feel about that as opposed to some
very product focused tech folks coming in?
>>Albert: So we've actually , I think passed
on a number of opportunities over the last
18 or 24 months that were sort of, of the
form, team comes in, it's four or five people.
They have a very aggressive plan.
But they have no line of code written and
they're looking to raise six or seven million
dollars and that makes us extremely nervous.
And those were very capable teams from the
business side, and both of those, the specific
deals I'm thinking of, both got funded by
other VC's.
But we, we didn’t think that, with that
kind of starting configuration that they would
have the DNA where technology would really
matter to the organization, and technology
would get built in a way to support the business
and there would be a product.
And we feel that for a lot of the successful
businesses on the web, a lot of the leverage
in the business comes from the technology
working.
And so for us having that sense that the technology
will work and will provide the leverage in
the business is pretty critical.
>>Chris: No
>> Dick: I knew, I knew, I knew you were going
to help me out. [Laughs]
>>Dave:
Yeah, I mean I think the answer is you wouldn't
invest in a team that generally didn't have
some sort of geek talent on it.
But I think the missing part of the question
is a lot of what we're investing in is consumer
internet and I think there’s a really significant
under emphasis on user experience and design
and sometimes when you say product, that is
that person.
But a lot of times when people say product
it’s just a smart person who uses the web.
And that doesn’t mean that they understand
user experience and really get that part of
it.
And that's really essential for most of the
consumer and small business internet services
we're building.
Even beyond that I think distribution is super
fuckin' important and people don't like, understand
how to do that.
And I'm not talking about traditional marketing
but people understand scalable like, distribution.
Be it search, be it social platforms.
Not just viral loops but any other type of
affiliate models.
So understanding how to build product is great
on the user experience side as well as the
code, and then how to do distribution I think
is really important.
>>Chris: Can I add a few words to my no?
>>Dick: Yeah
>>Chris: Thank You
>>Dick: I'm a kind and gentle moderator
>>Chris: One of the things when I look back
on, sort of all the, and we're casting this
as early stage investors…
>>Dick: Yeah.
>>Chris: coupled as founders.
>>Chris: The best companies, the founders,
whatever their skill sets are, whether it's
one founder, two founders, or three founders
-- each of the founders is completely and
totally obsessed with the product.
And so to Dave's point whether they're focused
on the distribution dynamics of the product
or they're actually the ones heads down building
the product or they're the person that is
thinking about market fit -- the product and
what the product’s gonna do.
The product is the orientation and that's
very different than, sort of the technical
founder who shows up and doesn't care so much
about the product but wants to be a co-founder
of a company that has a product.
>>Dick: Yeah
>>Chris: And so in those combinations you
almost, when you're obsessed with a product
you almost always have to have, by definition,
somebody on that founding team that’s technical
because it’s really hard to be obsessed
with a product unless you're actually like
building stuff and doing stuff.
The other thing I'd say to that is, I have
become completely allergic to the two MBA's
who outsourced the development to some consulting
firm to help them to get started because if
they haven't been able to figure out how to
attract somebody that’s going to live in
the product from the beginning.
Doesn't mean they can't use another firm to
help them get things up and going early on,
but one of those founders sort of obsessively
living in the product.
>>Dick: OK great.
You know you mentioned something I want to
jump right in on.
You mentioned coming in and founders talking
about market fit.
You guys all invested in somewhat – invested
in different lifecycles of the company.
Paul in from very, very, very early.
Brad and Albert, you guys'll do B and C's
as well as A – and Steve.
When you guys think about investing, Marc
Andreesen wrote a blog post -- I think it's
probably about two years ago now -- where
he talked about -- do I look for market or
the people or the product?
Right?
And he had a specific point of view on that.
Is there any specific, one of those three
that you guys say trumps the other two?
>>Paul: The people.
Markets I think, when people say that they
prefer markets over people, they're usually
people like Marc Andreesen who have such fabulous
deal flow, that all the people they see are
great.
And so among these great people they take
the ones that are also in great markets.
Right?
But unless you're in this weird situation,
really the people are the part that, that,
that you can't change, right?
You can take great people and they can completely
change their idea, at least at our stage they
frequently do.
You can't change the people.
So it's like with real estate, the one thing
you can't change about real estate is the
location right?
People is like that for a startup.
>>Chris: So a wise person when I used to write
code a long time ago said that the best way
to make progress is to simplify the problem.
And to reduce the dynamics and reduce the
constraints.
Something like that.
This was before object method programming
and Ruby On Rails, so that's a whole different
path.
The, ah, I have in our firm at Foundry Group,
we've eliminated one of those three things
which is market in that we only invest in
things where we really understand the market
and personally have huge affinity for
the markets that the companies that we're
investing in go after.
So that allows us to not worry about the market
dynamic with the entrepreneur on the front
end because we can eliminate that.
And it's I think another way, when if you're
an entrepreneur, a way to think about is if
you're able to participate in a market that
you understand really well, that gets rid
of one of the pieces of complexity.
Or if you can match up with investors who
understand the market really well that you're
going after, that gets rid of one of the pieces
of complexity that tends to be a very high
variable.
>>Albert: So I think a lot of this has changed
because the nature of the businesses has changed
in many ways.
So during the era where traditional enterprise
software was built, I think there was a style
of investing where people picked teams that
were known how to, they knew a particular
market for enterprise software, they had a
sales person, they had a person who knew how
to build something, they had a Spec person.
But on the consumer internet, what we find
is, one of the most powerful things that a
company can have is engaged users.
So it’s already launched, it has people
using the service, and they’re deeply engaged
in the service and there’s a feedback loop
that’s working between the users and the
people who are building the product.
And as a result we've backed a number of startups
that have people where, if you looked at those
people on paper anyhow, they certainly would
not have gotten funding for a traditional
enterprise startup ever under any, any kind
of set of circumstances.
But they've turned out to be great founders
for these kind of startups that are dealing
with engaged users, and dealing with products
where the design and the feel of the product
makes a big difference.
>>Dick: I'm going to, I'm gonna just ask one
more of my questions and then there are so
many people in here, I'm kind of gonna go
right to the Wave after that so we can get
lots of time for questions from the audience.
I think that’s always a better approach
in rooms that are this crowded. So my last
question that I'll ask you guys, and Mr. Dr
McClure I'll start with you 'since you're
sitting there pensively.
Is, so we see their eyes of open source and
a general embrace of openness and almost a
constant buzz in the embrace of openness.
Actually you're a perfect person for this
question.
But we also see the closed and proprietary
platforms like Apple, perform extremely well.
So purely from an investing perspective, how
do you think about open vs. proprietary?
>>Dave: So I'll take the bait here.
Channeling Steve Jobs, openness for losers.
[Quiet laughter from audience]
Proprietary standards are what in general
drive innovation and adoption.
And Open standards, sorry Proprietary drives
adoption and innovation.
And open standards lowers costs and widens
the market.
And there's definitely exceptions to those,
but I think most people who have cool products
and cool ideas want to preserve their advantage,
want to like establish sustainability.
>>David: Exception.
Exception; like the Internet for example.
[pause]
>>Chris: Or maybe Google.
Google sounds like an exception.
>>Dave: Yeaaahhh
>>Dave 2: HTTP. HTML being a, you know,
>>Dave: Yeah.
But I mean that was after, so Twitter is basically
a SMTP on a private basis.
Do you think like, like does it service well
that Twitter's controlled by one company?
No, we don't have a fuckin' choice, sorry.
You know, SMTP isn't, and yes we all get to
benefit from that.
But you know, Twitter's gonna make a lot of
money because Twitter is not an open standard.
>>David: So I think, you should, ah we’re
having this big Twitter battle on this topic,
so
>>Dave: So open standards definitely provide
foundations for other people to do amazing
things, I totally agree with that.
>>David: So, and every time you, every time
you advocate openness first of all, it always
evolves into like you’re a socialist or
something.
I'm a capitalist who believes that sometimes
having certain layers in the stack being open
actually increases overall Net innovation.
>>Dave: Sometimes.
>>David: And overall Net private wealth creation.
Now I’m not saying all that, you know, if
you're a Twitter share holder, maybe its better
to have that all accrued to that single company.
I would argue that having a subscription,
short subscription messaging protocol, be
open, the dominant one being open like SMTP
would lead to more Net private wealth creation.
It's a capitalist phrase not socialist, than
having it controlled by a single company.
So I think this should be an economic argument,
if you read, there's a lot of interesting
economic literature on the topic.
I blog about it and I link to it if you ever
want; CDixon.org.
But it's not a political debate in my mind
-- it's an economic debate and I think that,
like for example the fact that Http and HTML
seems to have opened some of the wealth creating
decisions of all time.
So I just don't think, I just, so to me it's...
>>Dave: The challenges there are that the
benefits of the wide open standard aren't
really available to everyone until it's open
and adopted as a standard
>>Dick: [interrupting] But it's just, just,
just...
>>Dave: On the way there it's not, it's a
lot of work for not a lot of compensation
when you're trying to get to that standard.
Whereas on a proprietary basis you can immediately
start extracting value from the things that
you're doing on a proprietary basis.
>>Chris: The neat thing about that...
>>Dick: [interrupting] Just about from an
investing perspective.
>>Chris: Yeah, from an investing perspective.
The neat thing is we're 5 minutes into the
debate and we're not answering the question.
So from an investing perspective, it doesn't
fucking matter.
[Audience laughter]
>>Chris: Really, really, really simple.
Massive companies have been built on proprietary,
massive companies have been built on open;
it's incredibly chaotic and dynamic.
That may be my wife, hang on.
Ah, it's my aunt.
It's my aunt I don't have to answer that.
[Audience laughter]
The thing that’s so fascinating about the
open vs. proprietary dynamic is the business
we're in is now so big and so chaotic and
changes so continually that the opportunity
to disrupt different segments exists.
If you asked IBM in the mid '50's whether
open vs. closed was a better strategy and
then you asked the government in 1960 whatever,
I mean, all of these things moved very slowly
and ponderously because they were driven by
one or two very large companies.
Today the disruption happens very widely and
I think that’s a source of innovation from
an investor perspective.
There's tons of opportunities in either place.
>>Paul: For startups, I mean, there’s, there’s
various senses of open, right?
There's like, software can be open source,
or protocols can be sort of public standards
decided by some slow moving committee.
That part doesn't sound so exciting for a
startup.
But the part that does sound exciting for
a startup is that there is just an enormous
number of programmers, and you guys in the
audience -- probably a lot of you are in this
group of people -- programmers want to write
code.
There's this hugely powerful force of people
who want to create things.
And if you have a start up where part of your
software can be created by the world at large,
right, then you can harness this enormous
force of all these people who don't work for
your company but wanna write code and be well
known or just produce something beautiful,
you know.
So to that extent, that’s exciting.
If people seem like they’ve got a start
up that somehow is gonna get code that's very
valuable to their company written by this
massive recently unleashed force, that’s
good.
>> Dick: Albert, do you have anything you
want to add?
>>Albert: Yeah.
I do think there's one level of openness that
does matter from an investing perspective
and that is sort of, the level of openness
at the internet level.
So I think we are not particularly concerned
that some people are trying to create within
the internet certain areas that they're trying
to control.
We're not concerned about Twitter trying to
do that, Facebook trying to do that, Apple
trying to do that within their realms, because
there's still the Internet at large.
So the only thing that we worry about from
an investment perspective is anything that
would kind of cut across the layers of the
internet. So, things like deep packet inspection
and traffic shaping at the access layer are
things that are of a concern because they
are things that unlevel the playing field
and make it hard potentially for you guys
to start the next Google.
And that is something that we do worry about.
>> Dick: Right.
I'm going to go already to the Wave with the
first question here.
Do you feel that web apps will replace the
need for native apps and if so, why?
And I guess we would then add on, tack onto
that, when you guys are evaluating questions
like this, like this one specifically right
here, how do you think about, what do you
look for when you think about competitive
advantage and how this is going to help or
hurt?
[pause]
Go ahead, Paul.
>>Paul: Are the questions ranked?
‘Cause that's such a great question.
Did that get voted up, or did it just accidentally
happen to be the first?
>>Dick: It's got a little bit of voting up.
There's been some voting up although it's
not totally Dory'd to use the Google term.
>>Paul: Ah, ‘cause that is a great question.
My answer is I hope so.
‘Cause I’m very afraid a world in which
we are all Steve Jobs' slaves.
[Audience laughter]
And I feel like [audience clapping] I mean,
>>Dave: as long as we're getting paid 70 cents
on the dollar it's a pretty good slavery though.
>>Paul: We're not, we’re not even fully
his slaves yet and he's band us from using
compilers, right?
3.3.1 I feel like if anything can save us
it might be Chrome actually. Not Androids.
>Dick: Pandering.
Minus one point for pandering to the audience
>>Paul: No, no, no. I just dissed Android
in the second half of the sentence. I meant
Chrome rather than Android.
Because...
>>Dave: If you had two startups come to you,
equal talent.
One developing for Android, one developing
for Apple – which one are you going to pick?
>>Paul: Oh God, are you kidding?
Of course, the iPhone.
I’m talking about what I hope will make
us free, not what I hope will generate a lot
of returns.
[Audience laughter]
Anyway, it's not the startups that are gonna
do this; it's the guys working on Chrome.
What the guys, what the guys working on Chrome
ought to do is just say screw standards, we're
just gonna like introduce all kinds of features
to Chrome that will make web apps be as powerful
as native iPhone apps, iPad apps, whatever.
So everybody can just write web apps, and
they don't have to be in the apps tour anymore.
[Inaudible comment from Dave]
Is that what Joe Hewitt says? Well, a smart
guy. [Audience laughter]
>>Dick: So Brad, Brad, how do you feel about
that question?
>>Chris: I was thinking about the question
a different way.
It feels too narrow a question ‘cause it’s
just focused on user facing apps.
We have a lot of investments that, they’re
not web app possible. We're invested in a
company called Oblong which was founded by
the guy who created the idea and the user
interface paradigm behind Minority Report.
He worked for Spielberg and this is a company
that’s growing like crazy.
Their thing is not a web app; it's a totally
different thing.
And they're some of the best developers and,
and coders I've ever worked with.
So I think this is a narrow question in the
context in a moment in time where we're now
dealing with HTML 5 vs. flash vs. a couple
of other things and we're going from a place
where the browser as a ubiquitous access point,
online still isn't a real thing but the browser
with the cache that’s active that actually
is intelligent and can be used offline without
a whole bunch of histrionics is a relevant
way to actually think about a programming
paradigm.
So I think five years from now this question
wouldn't be a relevant question ‘cause it’s
gonna shift again.
And it's gonna shift again about what’s
being built on top of what we're dealing with
today.
>>Albert: And I think that’s the most important
point from an investment perspective.
I think we would not look at something where
we would feel that the decisive factor and
the success or lack of that company was whether
or not web apps were going to dominate or
app apps.
So, I think things that approach things by
saying we're going to succeed in area X because
ours is a web app and the other guys is a
native app, probably not strong enough an
argument.
There has to be some other difference, more
meaningful to them
>>Chris: And it just occurred to me that probably
nobody in this audience thinks a native app
means something that’s installed on a Windows
7 desktop.
It just occurred to me, because five years
ago that’s probably what a native app would
have meant to most of the people in an audience
like this, so just to point to the shift again.
>>Dick: Chris I wanna, I wanna jump in, in
front of you saying something here ‘cause
I wanted to ask you a question on this point.
Brad mentioned investing in Oblong which is
this kind of out there crazy user interface,
that's all it really is, a user interface
right?
And you mentioned earlier investing in GLG;
Gerson Lehrman Group which is really investing
in a business model.
So to this kind of, how do you think about
X vs. Y, when you're looking at deals like,
when you invested in Gerson Lehrman Group
and for them, for the people in this audience
that are building something that’s like
totally out there, it's not an iPhone app,
it's not an iPad app, but it’s this new
kind of thing, how do you think about yes
I believe this will have sustainable competitive
advantage or Yeah I'd buy into that, right
when you're thinking something about an Oblong
or Gerson Lehrman Group?
>>Dave: Wow, there was a bunch of questions
in there. Um.
>>Dick: Well I'll narrow it down.
How do you think about sustainable competitive
advantage
>>Dave: sustainable competitive advantage
>>Dick: when you get pitched on something?
>>Dave: So you mean sort of building on equity
value that’s defensible.
I think, well I think like for example on
the consumer internet, you tend to see sort
of equity value, as it were, either through
a brand name, building a brand, like a real
consumer brand, network effects like Facebook
has incredible network effects; Twitter has
great network effects.
Where they can be network effects for users
or it can be what’s called complimentary
network effects which is with third party
developers so obviously Microsoft sort of
builds incredible sustainable competitive
advantage that way.
Or it can be pure technology which is less
frequent these days in sort of the web app
world.
My last company was in security, consumer,
computer security that tends to have some
areas like that, there tends to be sort of
actual technology advantage.
I mean of course anything you do as a startup
company, they can copy, it's just a question
of if it takes them 20 months and they have
some strategic reasons why they want to have
it built faster.
I think there was another question?
Well anyways, does that kind of get to what
you're asking?
>>Dick: Yeah. Sure.
>>Dave: I think a lot of times we’re too
focused on like what’s the technology du
jour and what’s kind of like cool and everything
and not so much just on basic distribution
and modernization, so.
As an investor the things I'm thinking of
right now are what platforms got me access
to 100 Million users or more and have decent
modernization, right?
So either on the distribution basis or modernization
basis I would say Facebook, Twitter, Native
search on Google, paid search on Google, YouTube
which most people don't think about as a distribution
platform, Apple, maybe Android in the future,
and then potentially I think Gmail is actually
interesting for us and bPlatform.
So like when you start to think about like
I'm in control of building a great product
‘cause I'm an engineer I know I can build
a great product.
If I'm customer focused, I can make sure people
like it.
Then the biggest challenge is how do I get
out to a bunch of users.
So, figuring out scalable distribution channels,
whether they're paid or free, is generally
not something that engineers know how to do
unless they’ve actually been in a company
where that’s been you know, part of the
ethos.
So I know you probably know how to build a
product, if you have a good designer or user
experience pro, person on staff, you might
actually get the user to understand that you've
got a good product, but then you got to get
it out to a hundred thousand people and I
don't think we pay enough attention to how
do we do the distribution layers.
>>Dick: This has been the question up here
that’s been voted up here a lot is a simple
one; what is your favorite kind of investment.
Why don't we start with Albert and go down,
go down the line?
>>Albert: The one that makes money
>>Dick: Yes. Which leads then to the second
part of that question which is what are the
kinds of returns you expect to see or hope
to see?
>>Albert: I actually did want to come back
to this question.
Sorry.
I really think that this question of what
is sustainable competitive advantage is a
much more interesting one because I do think
that there was a longer technology cycle some
time where there was real technology differentiation
mattered a lot.
And it’s not clear that that’s how significant
that's going to be in the future.
So one that wasn't mentioned, and I think
it’s very important to mention is data.
So you could come up with a much better, quote
unquote, algorithm than Google, but it wouldn't
help you very much because you wouldn't have
access to the search volume, or the historic
search data.
So we think a lot about data assets as being
one of the few things that’s actually defensible.
I've recently for some reason, sometimes startups
come in bunches, I've seen a whole bunch of
startups that are all in the we're going to
monitor your cloud infrastructure or your
servers in the cloud and they all have roughly
the same feature set, so when you think about
how they compete with each other, the only
thing that really matters is who gets the
most servers quickly and does the best job
with that data.
That’s gonna be virtually impossible for
anybody who starts later to replicate.
[Pause]
Sorry I didn't answer the other question.
>>Dave: Answer the other question.
>>Albert: No, no.
I've passed the microphone
>>Chris: So as a firm foundry group invests
in a handful of very broad horizontal themes
so I don't have a favorite amongst those,
but I'll describe one, so that you get sort
of the sense of how I think about it at least.
I, I have a long standing premise that if
you go forward 20 years, the way that we interact
with computing and computer devices and software
will be radically different than we do today.
And just this conference is an example.
If you think about how you interacted with
computing and data and software 20 years ago
vs. how you're doing it in real time here,
it's completely different.
I think the idea that people have laptops
in their laps that are connected and they're
looking up at a screen with stuff like this
in this kind of interaction paradigm is not
how it's gonna be 20 years from now.
And in 40 years I think hopefully the machines
will be friendly to us.
[Audience laughter].
And so that's a deeply held belief.
And so I'm completely focused from an investment
perspective in things that are addressing
that with that kind of an arc.
I want to be an investor in companies that
are radically changing the way that we interact
with mice, keyboards, data, interface, etc.
And that’s a theme of ours we call Human
Computer Interaction.
It covers a lot of different places, and there's
an awful lot of stuff in that, in that, in
that zone that we wouldn't invest in.
But it’s interesting when you land on something
as an investor where, and obviously you have
to have deep technical roots to be able to
do some of this stuff because they're hard
things.
But you also have to have a level of creativity
where you can look forward in terms of how
we're gonna interact and how we're gonna think
about that interaction.
So I mean I could drill through the other
things that we have but that’s an example,
one of the things that gets me excited.
>>Dave: I think there's different dynamics
for large VC vs. small VC. Large VC, one lets
say that’s 250 million dollars in greater
under management
>>Chris: That’s still small VC.
>>Dave: How much?
Yeah OK.
I mean I think you have to create new ecosystems
and platforms right.
So you have to envision the new Facebook,
the new Google, the new whatever.
Whereas smaller investors can probably play
into existing ecosystems and create businesses
that are like riding on top of this.
So I think I like business where I understand
what problems being solved.
I don't necessarily need you to create the
next greatest browser, you know phone device,
whatever.
I want you to figure out how to teach my kids
to read Spanish.
And that’s like not necessarily a sexy problem,
but I tell you if you figured like an online
education product for kids to learn Spanish
in the U.S between the ages of zero and Seven,
I'm fuckin' interested.
That’s a big market.
People are gonna pay for that.
Probably Mandarin too, at least in another
five years, so like don't, I don't think most
people do that.
I think there's a lot of entrepreneurs that
are, for lack of any better description, are
young male, white, under 25 with glasses,
that are left handed, and they’re building
games and entertainment and music things that
they like to use.
And I don't think there's enough people in
the 30-50 demographic with kids that are building
stuff, and that audience is very much online
these days, that's very monetizable and I
would encourage the entrepreneurs in the audience
to talk to your moms and talk to your uncles
and aunts and parents and like figure out
what kind of problems they have and solve
some of those.
‘Cause they're a lot easier to monetize
than the next damn newsreader or music service.
>>Chris: Let me challenge one thing that you
said which is I think,
I think, I'd argue a dichotomy between sort
of large fund vs. small fund dynamic.
I think it’s horizontal thinker vs. vertical
thinker, and I think you find them all over
the place, you find them in different places.
So what Dave just described was a very vertical
market segmentation type of application which
I think that, there's, there is a lot of places
where there’s opportunity there, where there
aren’t that many people chasing after it.
Then I think there's horizontal opportunities
which could be a new platform, but they could
also be something that touches lots of different
types of customers, much more generalizable.
And I actually think that independent of fund
size, big or small, you can be a successful
investor in either place, but I think it's
very hard to be a successful investor in both
types.
So when I've experienced other VC's that have
tried to invest in vertical things and horizontal
things they tend to get tangled up in it.
You have to have a framework for how to think
about it.
And I think as entrepreneurs, a lot of entrepreneurs
get whiplashed from VC's who say well go after
your first vertical market, you have to go
find some customers, dah dah dah dah dah,
and that’s going to evolve into a horizontal
thing.
When in fact the right approach to it is to
define the horizontal thing, build the infrastructure,
a la Twitter, and then worry about the vertical
segmentation of it down the road.
I'm not making an opinion about one being
better than the other; I think they're just
very hard to mix together in the same person's
brain.
>>David: Breadth versus Depth versus programmer
>>Chris: Yeah.
>>Dick: So Chris what’s your, what are your,
what are the things you look at that you say
this is really super appealing to me?
>>Chris: So I do investing on the side, and
I'm fulltime working on a startup.
And I had a previous startup
>>Dick: You don't have to apologize for investing.
>>Chris: [laughs] I just wanna say that
>>Dave: It's OK to be a VC.
>>Chris: So I've pitched many, many VC's and
I sit there in these meetings, and most of
them are sort of saying OK like, my last company
was called Site Advisor, an internet security
company, and they were like OK let me analyze,
I don’t know anything about consumer securities
right now, but let me go and learn about it
and try to predict the future and decide whether
your idea is good.
And I just think that method is a really bad
method for investing.
I mean I think, this is what is called thesis
driven investing.
I think it's possible to do well if you're
very focused, like I think the Union Square
team and I think Brad is. I, I just sort of
think it's like a form of intellectual modesty
to say I can't predict the future so for example,
and I've just become from thinking like it's
80% about people to it's 99.9% about people,
so I just invested in you know, Moot's new
thing, he's a 4Gen guy, he's like this 21
year old and he's created this thing that’s
got 10 million kids using it.
I mean the idea that I’m gonna go in and
like analyze what the 21 years olds are gonna
do tomorrow, I mean I think it's preposterous.
All I know is this guy has done a lot of really
cool stuff, and I like to, I like to back
people like that.
And I'm not going to try to predict the future.
I guess I'm sort of copying here off Paul’s
methods.
>>Paul: I had a long time to think about the
answer to this question, sitting on the end
here.
So I went through various answers actually
for what my favorite kind of investment was,
but I decided in the end it's the company,
the idea that’s just on the right side of
crazy.
Because just as with scientific ideas the
very best, you know the most exciting scientific
papers, are the kind that draws some, actually
this is true for mathematical proofs too,
that end up with some conclusion that makes
you say really?
That’s true?
And the most exciting sort of startups to
work on and impossibly also the highest returning
ones are the ones that have ideas that are
so out there, they just really seem dubious
when you first start.
So I remember Air BnB for example.
When they first came to us I said, really?
People wanna like stay on one another’s
sofas and stuff?
And they said yeah it's true, we’re surprised
too, but they do.
[Laughs]
Right?
And like those guys, I mean, I'm not even
supposed to tell you how well those guys are
doing actually, ah, they're really doing well.
So I love that kind of thing.
And it would be, it would be great if that
turned out to be the kind of startup that
had the highest returns too because then my,
my selfish desires and my responsibility to
our investors would, would line up.
>>Albert: One word that we think about a lot
when we think about what our favorite startups
are is the word Native.
Which is, if you take certain enterprise systems
for example, people are saying well I'm gonna
do the same thing that Enterprise company
XY is doing, and I'm gonna do it on the web
and I’m gonna make it 20% cheaper, or 20%
faster.
And that’s not native to the web.
So native to the web is trying to figure out
what could I do on the web that the enterprise
company could've never done and will never
be able to do.
What can I do on a mobile phone that can't
be done on a browser that sits on somebody’s
laptop?
How do I make use of something that's native,
completely native to that experience?
And so we think the most interesting startups
are the ones that figure out what the native
model is that’s now enabled that didn’t
exist previously and often those native models
tend to sound crazy at first, like we're gonna
give the software away.
It’s gonna be completely free.
>>Paul: And the first version is derided as
a toy.
>>Albert: Yes.
>>Paul: Right?
>>Albert: Yes
>>Paul: That's very important.
We look for that actually.
When people build something they say oh it
works, but this is a toy, this isn't serious.
Not yet.
It's like micro computers, right?
Toy computers.
>>Dick: Ah, I'm gonna, Albert, you're now
in charge of managing the Wave so you have
to refresh it once in a while.
I'm delegating while I ask the next question.
Which is, so again I'm trying to think of
questions here from the perspective of entrepreneurs
in the audience.
One of the things that frustrated a lot of
entrepreneurs that I know, would be they'd
go into investors and pitch them and the investors
would say look I like the product, I like
the technical founders but I don't think you
guys are gonna be, should be the managers
of the company, right?
What, when is it OK for the founders, the
tech founders to manage the, to be the managers
of the company?
When is it not?
And do you really know at the beginning or
do you give them a chance to try and manage
it themselves?
>>Paul: If they want to.
If they wanna be the managers, they should
be the managers.
And if they don't, they shouldn’t.
I mean maybe if we were later stage and we
had to deal with disasters caused by people,
by hackers who weren't suitable to manage
corporations maybe we would think differently.
But in our world at least, if the founders
wanna be in charge, they can be in charge;
if they wanna get somebody else to be in charge,
they can.
Whatever they want.
>>Dick: Sure, but so, let me just -- let’s
push back on that a little bit. We've all
heard of the, at least I’ve heard of the
situation where entrepreneurs go in and pitch
a seed round or an A round, and they get back
“you guys are great, you're passionate.
I don't really think you guys are the guys
to run this company.”
What's happening there?
What are the dynamics there?
What should the people in the audience...
>>Paul: You get that less and less actually.
VC's, even VC's that are notorious for firing
founders seem to be coming around to doing
it less.
They've learned that like, you fire the founders,
the company sucks anyway, and all you get
is a bunch of bad PR and it doesn't really
improve your returns.
You’re gonna make the big money from Google,
you know, not from some...
>>David: I think you deal with the good VC's
‘cause there's still, there's still plenty
of VC's I see that do this, that play these
games.
I saw something recently where a guy who'd
joined up with an MIT scientist and then the
VC's tried to like cut and go directly to
the scientist and cut.
I mean it's still happening.
It's just ridiculous.
It’s like, I think, you look at the good
VC's, they bet, they find great teams like
you guys do or, and they bet on them and maybe
three years down the road, when you're like
growing really big you bring in, you know,
with the consent of the founders professional
management, but the idea of like switching
out early is just I think, disastrous and
unethical in many cases.
>>Chris: I think there's a, there is a nuance
that’s the difference between switching
out early and the VC not being able to just
say I'm just not interested, which is sometimes
what you're getting as code for I'm not interested.
And a situation where you're raising an early
stage round and you’re going after something
that is very big and you acknowledge that
it's very big, and whether it's, in Paul’s
language, you don't wanna be the person running
it, or you really need a partner for some
reason, the bad behavior is to simply tell
you your not the right person.
The good behavior at least from my perspective
is to say we really like what you're doing,
we're really interested in working with you,
you need another person on the team that looks
like this.
And that person might be CEO, it might be
a COO, it might be a technical co-founder
but you need another person in the box.
And we're gonna help you, not by pushing our
guy or gal on you, but by here's some people
that we know.
And that's what becomes interesting to us,
and you help us find that.
I've been through this a handful of times
with seed stage companies.
NewsGator which I'm an investor in is one
the co-founder was, or the founder was CTO
or he was a CTO and he thought he wanted to
be a CEO but he didn’t know what being a
CEO was.
And he actually didn’t want to be the CEO,
he wanted to be the CTO, he just didn’t
know what that meant.
And the VC saying after you've made the investment,
“OK now I need to bring my boy in,” is
really crappy.
The VC saying before the investment “Hey
I'm not sure you really know what you wanna
do here Mr. first time entrepreneur, let's
talk about it some more and go deeper.”
I think that’s a constructive conversation.
>>Dave: I think that there's like intellectual
honesty which is important in the founders
in understanding like what part of the company
cycle you're driving and what you're qualified
to do is important.
So I'm not gonna like, fire any founders.
I'm generally not taking any board seats so
I'm not doing that anyway but it does piss
me off when there’s people who are running
these companies who are obviously not qualified
to be doing the things they're trying to do
and they're not honest with themselves about
being the person to do it.
So like, you could simplify and say, you know,
there's three sort of basic stages that you
roll through as a company, which is Product,
Market, Revenue.
Like, can you build the product?
Ok great.
That someone likes to use.
How big is the market, or what market can
you actually get to that you can get distribution
into?
That may be a different role than the person
who’s building the product and that person
doesn’t have to run the company but you
need to have them in the organization.
But then at some point you need to be scalably
sustainable at some level.
You can't keep raising money forever, unless
you're Jeff Bezos.
[laughs]
And I think having a timeframe under which
you reach some level of sustainable revenue
is important.
So those three things are very different roles.
There's very few people who as CEO's can manage
the transition from each of those things.
Can you build the product?
Can you scale the product to a large audience?
And can you manage a large organization sustainably
and financially?
>>Chris: I would only add one more thing to
that, which is, if I look backwards on the
portfolio that we built in the last 3 or 4
years, which is 20 something companies.
On almost every case the founding team is
the team that's running the business.
So, coming back to the people thing, I think
there is, we're really focused on that founding
team at the beginning which might incorporate
a new person who’s not there in that first
meeting, but that’s the team that becomes
the team that builds the business.
And augmenting that founding team with the
right people is much more important than firing
somebody and bringing in a new person.
Because then I totally agree with Paul having
been through this historically a lot.
The company's fucked and you may as well move
on.
And there are very few cases where you get
recovery from that.
And the one exception is when you get to the
sort of product step function, you're out
20, 30 million bucks and you've now transitioned
from this hyper growth business to one that’s
profitable and the original CEO entrepreneur
runs out of gas because of their own experience,
and that does happen sometimes.
And that’s I think where the intellectual
honesty comes in.
>>Dick: Can we get a microphone going around
in the room; I think there's some in the back
somewhere?
[Inaudible comment from audience member]
>>Dick: Aha.
Yeah.
I also want to get a microphone going around
just so people can ask questions from the
audience.
But three second gut check, let’s do this
one.
Three second gut check; would you invest in,
if I ask for a, if I ask for a, how ever you
pronounce that word?
The, ah, you know what I mean.
>>David: I haven't met the team.
I'd wanna meet them first.
>>Dick: The open Facebook thing.
>>David: But I think investing in a direct
competitor of Facebook is probably not a value
creating activity.
[Laughter from audience]
>>Dick: All right.
Ok, perfect.
This is great.
All right.
What are some of the, perfect, now they're
rated.
What are some of the big no-no's for startups.
Let’s go, let’s go Paul, start with you
this time.
>>Paul: Give me that.
The biggest like, some big no-no's, boy there’s
so many no-no's.
It's a world of no-no's.
>>Dick: Let’s go your big, for each of you
what’s the biggest, like Oh my God.
>>Paul: Taking too long, too long to launch
and in building something for like some theoretical
user that you believe exists somewhere but
is not you or anybody you actually know.
[Audience laughter]
>>David: Well I think you had a great post
didn't you recently, like 22 no-no's or something?
>>Paul: 18
>>David: 18 no-no's, which I probably agree
with all of those.
I think it's all about beginning the team,
finding the right people.
It’s like a marriage.
That's it.
>>Dick: Dave’s looking at Paul’s Post
now.
>>Dave: Yeah. I was just gonna recreate the
post.
Just fuckin' launch, I mean that's...
Well actually the other thing is gathering
a whole bunch of analytics that you don't
do anything with.
So like, it's great that you have some big
ass Google analytics report with all sorts
of graphs and charts.
But if you don't like make a decision about
your product or your market based on the analytics,
they're fucking worthless and it's a waste
of time.
>>Chris: So I'll do one very general, one
very specific
>>Dick: You two are like enabling each other
to swear more, I'm noticing. Brad and
>>Chris: I didn't swear, that wasn't swearing,
I was going to swear.
>>Dick: All right, I’m going to let it go
for now.
[Audience laughter]
>>Chris: What’s wrong with that? So, so
the general one that’s a no-no in my mind
is fear. So every single person in this room
is going to die. That is a fact.
>>Albert: [inaudible comment]
>>Chris: No.
You will die, you will die.
There may be some changes that prevent you
from dying, but based on current reality you
will die.
[Inaudible comments from audience].
That's true.
So I believe in the context of being a startup
entrepreneur, fear is not useful, where fear
is a construct that is fear of uncontrollable
and unknowable things.
Which is linked directly to just Launch.
Right?
Again I said I was being abstract.
The entrepreneurs who are tentative, hesitant,
uncomfortable, afraid, hold back; that’s
a warning sign.
The ones that are willing to make mistakes,
screw up, throw it away, try again, keep going
and just drive forward, those are the ones
that I wanna work with.
>>Dick: Is that a, is that a corollary to
the old , you know the, the, the, I think
it's a Winston Churchill quote which is something
like I'd rather make a, a , a, I'd rather
make a 100 decisions, 51 of which were right
rather than as opposed to two great decisions.
>>Chris: Absolutely.
You need to make the two great decisions in
the context of a startup or you won't be successful.
And Winston Churchill made a couple of great
decisions along with the ones that he made
wrong.
But he was willing to make a lot of decisions
versus hang around and optimize for those
exact one or two.
>>Albert. Um, two big no-no's I think are
doing too many things, not being focused.
And confusing venture capital as a goal as
opposed to a means.
>>Dick.: OK. Is proof of concept always needed
to get Capital? Or what stage does a company
need to be at when they deliver?
So Paul, I know you’re gonna answer.
>>Paul: If they really mean VC, usually yes.
Maybe if you were a super famous person, you
know like Moot or something like that.
>>Dick: Or MC Hammer.
>>Paul: [laughs] Yeah.
You wouldn't need to.
But for ordinary, ordinary people, yes.
I mean if the VC's don't already know your
name, then you gotta have some kind of proof.
I mean I'm assuming that this means literally
VC, like series A rounds. I mean it’s not
needed for us.
>>David: I would say like, that in defense
of Moot, that the important thing with Moot
was not that he was a celebrity.
The important thing was that he built interesting
stuff.
Right?
Like.
Yeah yeah.
That to me is, so I think it's more like you've
built something, whether the thing you've
built is the thing you're pitching is separate.
But I'm much more impressed by somebody who
can come in and say I built this open source
project or I did some, whatever, built something,
than I am whatever, resume, or mockups or
whatever.
>>Dave: Yeah and just on that previous thing
that we were talking about product market
team before.
Product is the mirror for team.
Like you can tell me you've got a great team
but if your product blows and you've been
at it for a while, like sorry you don't have
a great team.
[Laughs].
So like as much as team matters, product is
the evidence of their efforts and the product
should be awesome.
>>Chris: I think especially if you take a
developer perspective to the question, as
an investor whether I'm doing a seed investment
or a series A investment, it's generally true.
It's much more impressive to play with and
react to the thing you've created than go
through a PowerPoint presentation, right?
And in fact I don't want to go through that
PowerPoint presentation; I don't want you
spending your time on that.
I want you spending your time on building
something and getting it out there for people
to play with
That's your PowerPoint presentation.
>>Dick: I remember pitching you Feedburner
and on like slide one you were like uhuh,
uhuh, uhuh.
Well all right, we'll just put this slide
aside.
>>Dave: But at the same time you can go a
little long on product.
I mean like it's great to show me product
for 5, 10, 15 minutes.
But after like 35 minutes, I kind of wanna
know hey do you have any kind of business
model?
Do you know, have you done any customer surveys
on the product that you're showing me?
Like it's not the only thing.
>>Dick: Yeah.
>>Albert: Nothing bad.
>>Dick: Nothing bad.
Ah, OK there was another, OK here it is.
What’s the largest social issue that the
brightest mind should be working on tackling?
And I think this is one you could probably
talk about for 10 minutes or 20 minutes or
so but just, if you had to pick one, what’s
a social issue that you think that people
should be working on and using technology
to solve.
>>Paul: I know this sounds really boring but
I mean, if you could figure out a way to like
make electric power generation 1% more efficient.
That would just improve people's lives enormously,
right?
These little mundane things are actually much
bigger than you know, curing one particular
dramatic disease.
So I would say actually odd as this seems,
this is one big thing I look for; introducing
market pricing to do a means that didn't have
it previously, right.
>>David: I think in at least the IT space,
probably education.
I think there's a lot of opportunity there.
>>Dave: I'm a big fan of using financial engineering
to open up markets that previously didn't
exist.
So micro finance is one particularly amazing
thing.
But like, mortgage markets, before mortgage
markets existed, like that was a pretty cool
piece of technology in its day.
I mean the last 10 years of like financial
crisis aside we are a better society as a
result of
[background laughter and banter]
>>Dick: Chris’ comment was ‘that worked
well’.
>>Dave: the mortgage crisis.
It’s easy to pile onto that shit and like
there are many, many, many people who could
not buy homes 100 years ago because we didn’t
have the advent of financial markets and mortgage
markets and in the other countries not in
the U.S where we don't have savings and other
law in property rights.
That’s really important to capital formation
so financial engineering is a technology that
I think too many people don't pay attention
to because it can move mountains.
>>Chris: This room is full of very smart people.
I think the best thing that everybody in this
room could do is allocate a small portion
of their energy to making the rest of society
smarter.
So back to education.
If you look at the correlation between human
progress and education, direct correlation.
And I think if you look at our government
and the government dynamics and if we could
tell the government stop messing around with
stuff and just put all that money into education,
make us smarter as a country, or whatever
country you're from, that would have huge
impact.
>>Albert: Making education free for everybody.
Which I think is possible with the internet.
>>Dick: We're gonna combine a couple of questions
here.
One I see up here and one I saw earlier.
I'm gonna, I’m gonna interpret the third
one up there.
How do you guys value companies when they’re
pre-revenue?
Right?
I think that’s another question entrepreneurs
have all the time.
And then I think I'll combine that with, combine
that with, there was a question earlier that
said is there another investing, are we in
another bubble in the investing side?
We're starting to see startups with crazy
valuations again.
And is this just gonna constantly keep on
happening where you go up and down up and
down, up and down every other year?
Or, or, is it going to accelerate?
Is it gonna stabilize?
How do you guys think about that?
Right?
And I'm asking it from the perspective of
those entrepreneurs in the audience who hear
that, this question and answer thing got valued
at a Bazillion dollars and then they've got
something that they think is a lot farther
along and then they hear from a VC you know,
I'll give you one on two pre.
So how do you guys – how should they be
thinking about that?
Is it just supply and demand?
>>Chris: I would actually say, let me start
with the, the bubble dynamics.
And I've been investing since -- I started
investing in 1994 with my own money, so I’ve
been sort of through a couple of cycles now.
Don't, as an entrepreneur who's raising money,
don't over value your imperfect market data
to drive your thought process.
If you’re trying to create a really large
business over a long period of time, you're
gonna go through whatever those dynamics are
and you want to create a situation where you
are in a position where you have control over
what’s going on as quickly as you can.
That’s gonna drive the largest ownership
of the business.
If you try to optimize at every valuation
point, you’ll get confused based on what
the market dynamic is.
So personally I actually don't pay that much
attention to the broad market dynamic ‘cause
I figure it’s gonna go up, and it gonna
go down, it's gonna move around.
I focus as an investor much more in do I want
to be a partner with the people in this company
trying to build something really significant.
And I go back to I think there's a bunch of
VC's who are very mathematically oriented,
I need to have a certain percentage of the
company, I have to get this much money to
work, blah blah blah blah blah.
It's total bullshit.
I mean the great people wanna be invested
with great entrepreneurs on things that could
be enormous.
And that's what you should be looking for
in an investor.
And as an entrepreneur you should be trying
to create something that has that kind of
potential and that’ll drive it more than
the macro stuff.
>>Dick: Albert do you have anything you want
to add?
[Pause]
Ok I'm going to hop to one more question that
I, that I, go ahead.
Albert looks like...
>>Chris: it's either a really great answer
or a really crappy answer.
One of the two.
[Albert tries to talk, but is over spoken
by Dave]
>>Dave: So no product – zero to 1 million.
Product/No customer -- 1-2 million.
Product and customer, not profitable -- 2-3
million.
Product, customer, profitable; 3-5 million
pre.
5 million final offer.
[pause]
Done?
>>Albert: I do think that there are these
waves.
But I also think there's also something else
going on which is in some of these areas,
there’s been almost a winner takes all but
certainly a difference of you know, several,
one or two orders of magnitude in value between
the leading company and the second company.
And so if you think that you're investing
in the leader, almost any price at which you
invest will turn out to have been a good price.
I remember when somebody was investing in
Facebook at a Billion, and people were like
ick, that’s crazy.
Well that turns out at least as of right now,
to seem to have been a pretty good investment.
So I think that when you have dynamics, in
areas where you have dynamics where they could
be winner take all effects, the distortions
in the valuations could be very, very substantial
that result from that.
>>David: I think there’s two real quick
things.
One is you can't make a great company through
financing but you can kill it through bad
financing.
And so I see in New York, you have this epidemic
of like hedge fund people investing at way
too high valuations and they come back and
they can't raise money and no one wants to
do a down round and it kind of kills the company.
I think that...
>>Dick: I think that’s an important thing
to kind of stress and maybe explain to people
what you’re talking about there ‘cause
I think, I think that’s a mistake that entrepreneurs
make a lot.
Like they maximize, they optimize for valuation
early on as opposed to other aspects of the
deal and they get themselves stuck.
>>David: Yeah I think it sounds self serving
for any of us to say this, but I think it's
true.
I think you should think about net dilution
over time, and I think if you took one pre
from Albert, sorry, if you took one on two,
$1 million on a $2 million valuation of let’s
say, just throwing out some numbers, versus
$8 million at an $8 million valuation from
some third tier VC, I bet you that you'd have
by the end, you'll have a more successful
company and you'll own more of it going with
the good guys.
And so I think one of the things actually
I think like why Y Culminator has been phenomenal
a lot, I think just the kids today are just
vastly more intelligent than like I was, in
that they think a lot about net dilution over
time and they think about raising just enough
money to kind of hit and create a milestone.
And then as you go on, you can go get the
dumber money or whatever, and then when you
sell it, who gives a, you just do it for price.
But at the early stage you're partnering.
>>Dick: Did you have anything else you wanted
to add there Albert?
Are there any questions in the audience, anyone?
Yes.
Right up here at the front.
I'll repeat it.
[Audience question]
You mentioned that creating education which
should be free for everyone is a great social
goal, that you'd be willing to invest in that,
or is just a great social goal?
>>Dick: So the question is, you mentioned
free education for everyone is a great social
goal, but would you really be willing to invest
in that or is it just a social goal?
>>Paul: In a way yes, because if you think
how would free education for everyone work?
It would probably be everyone educates one
another right?
It doesn't mean like, you have the existing
people who teach for money and they do it
for free.
It would be more peer to peer.
So if you invest in websites where people
communicate with one another, you are investing
in that.
And I hesitate to bring up this example because
it is less true now.
But when we first funded Readit, it was pretty
erudite.
And people were sort of caricatured on that,
on that account.
So if you invest in companies where people
talk peer to peer, that is that.
>>Albert: Also certain services can be free
to almost everybody but still monetize some
high value transactions.
I think our favorite example of that is Craigslist.
And you know Craigslist is mostly free and
most of what takes place on Craigslist is
free but certain high value transactions are
monetized but we would have loved being an
investor in Craigslist.
So if we can build the equivalent for education,
it could make education free for almost everything.
But there might be some small component that
actually sustains the business.
>>Dave: I think a version of open I really
do like, is where you see an existing market
that’s really high pricing, like really
painful and you find somebody who's willing
to charge a much lower amount and blow up
that market.
And basically it's close enough to a lot of
things that feel like free and open to be
that way.
And so Skype in its day had done that.
Albert and I are investors in a company called
Twilio that I feel is doing that right now
to Telecom.
And so, any place you can find somebody like
trying to extract really premium pricing but
not really delivering a lot of value and you
can cut them off at the knees by offering
something at 10% or less of their pricing,
like that’s a really interesting and exciting
business to go after.
>>Dick: Other questions? Yes.
[Inaudible audience question]
>>Dick: How important is previous experience
with co-founders and what do you look for
in that experience?
>>Paul: You mean previous experience with
your co-founders or do you mean previous experience
among the co-founders?
[Audience reply]
>>Paul: To us, not super important but we're
super early stage so it might be different
among, among actual VC's
>>Chris: I'm not sure there's a distinction
between, among, and with in that context so
let me, let me be more, no, no, no, but I,
I, I can interpret it either way actually.
If you have, if you're a first time entrepreneur
your run time of other life experiences with
your co-founders, I value that a lot.
If you're an experienced entrepreneur and
you've done it before, I value it less.
Because the problem or one of the challenges
that I've run into in the first time entrepreneur
cycle is that there’s so many different
things that you're getting stressed on that
you haven't experienced before, that having
some history together, whatever the context
is, tends to be helpful.
Once you've been through the cycle at least
once as an entrepreneur and you're on your
second or third company, it’s so useful
but not nearly as impactful.
That’s why I just wanted to clarify kind
of that.
>>Albert: And for founders who have not worked
together and are first time founders, something
that is very, very, very important is the
vesting of founder shares.
I've seen all sorts of crazy things including
people leaving and going to an Ashram and
you don't want to have to replace those shares
with your own shares.
>>Paul: Let me tell you something.
If you guys start a startup with someone,
and one of your co-founders doesn't want vesting,
they are gonna bail.
This is an almost invariable rule.
If whenever, almost every time we have someone,
we always suggest have four year vesting with
a one year cliff, especially the one year
cliff, and practically every time there has
been a group that ignored our advice, one
of the guys left.
And it was ‘cause this guy was thinking
of leaving that he insisted on not having
the cliff.
So have a cliff or don't do it.
>>Dave: I think one thing about investing
for most of us here, is we're probably investing
before product market fit, not after.
Chris wrote a great post about sort of the
vast scarcity of investors before product
market fit and the like feeding frenzy after
market fit, and I think really the secret
is trying to figure out what other metrics
than just revenue or uniques are you using
to figure out, like whether the company actually
has value or the people have value.
And I think our version of diligence is a
quick first check and a thoughtful second
check.
Which is we need to make a quick assessment
on whether you have some ability to build
shit and get it out the door and write you
a small first check.
And not think about that too much and then
six months later, have you actually got something
of value?
Great.
Then we're gonna think about whether we're
gonna do, you know, for those of us who are
follow on investors, whether we're gonna do
a larger second check into the company.
>>Dick: I think that’s all we have time
for.
It's 4 o’clock.
So thanks everyone for coming and being patient
here towards the end.
Thank you very much.